un lieu d'exception pour un enseignement
d'exception c'est ici face au château de
versailles dans ces bâtiments classés
monuments historiques qui a imaginé le
monde de demain
1200 futurs architectes conçoivent
chaque jour des réalisations innovantes
en ce moment nous on travaille dans une
grande pièce avec deux fenêtres de part
et d'autre et en fait on cherchait à
créer un courant d'air et à venir
récupérer le son du coup de l'extérieur
donc pour ça on a créé un tube avec des
entonnoirs et des enseignants
d'architecturé de design et d'arts
plastiques qui se mettent ensemble et
qu'il faut travailler sur des étudiants
sur des installations sonores dans
l'école ça apprend que le son n'est pas
forcément un ennemi de l'architecte
c'est à dire que le son c'est une
qualité positive des espaces arts
plastiques sciences et ingénierie une
formation pluridisciplinaire pour
répondre aux enjeux sociaux économiques
et écologiques du monde qui nous entoure
cent dix neuf enseignants accompagne
durant cinq ans les étudiants et pousse
la réflexion autour de l'avenir de
l'architecturé c'est l'arche est dur de
demain je vous dirai pas y aller
si l envers en métal si elle est pointue
ou rondes
peu importe je pense qu'elle sera
surtout capable de
beaucoup moins consommatrices l'école
favorise un terrain qui invite les
étudiants à chercher à construire à
prendre position pour améliorer sans
cesse il ya une très belle formule
d'hannah arendt qui dit les activités
humaines ne peuvent prétendre à
l'excellence
si on ne leur offre pas le terrain pour
s'accomplir un terrain qui sera ouvert
au public lors des journées nationales
de l'architecturé l'occasion de
découvrir l'escalier de la curiosité qui
présente une année de travaux
d'étudiants des visites guidées en
musique seront également proposés